[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw this story i followed this story
i still don't understand this story and
that's why i bring in mike florio from
pro football talk live the co-host with
chris sims
every morning monday through friday
preceding this show on peacock
it's the story of deandre baker who
played for the giants
or at least i think he played for the
giants and now he's with the kansas city
chiefs he's got a chance to play
for a super bowl ring who would have
thought we'd be in this position mike so
explain to the audience
the deandre baker situation
well it's funny you don't understand it
you assume i understand it
i'm not sure anybody understands you're
a lawyer incident back in may
involving deandre baker and quentin
dunbar where the allegation
was that they committed armed robbery
at a house party and as
the days and weeks went by there
became a sense that maybe
the witnesses slash victims were
changing their stories and maybe people
were seeking money
and it all got very confusing and murky
and it's entirely possible that
something happened that shouldn't have
happened
but once the witnesses essentially are
disqualified by this financial angle and
you had
a lawyer representing the witnesses
slash victims who ended up being
arrested for extortion
you know it's possible something
happened that didn't happen and then
somebody saw an opportunity to make some
money off of it
and the next thing you know the whole
case falls apart because no one can
testify now because
everyone's been corrupted by this one
way or the other so the end result is
quentin dunbar never got charged he's
still playing and has been playing for
the seahawks
baker was charged was cut by the giants
was reinstated by the league from the
commissioner exempt list and now
is a member of the chief's practice
squad so who knows what ultimately did
happen on that evening in may but the
end result is
there's no one who can take a witness
stand and ultimately provide the kind of
evidence that would convict someone
beyond a reasonable doubt
so no one's getting charged no one's
going to jail
except maybe people who are involved in
this scam to turn the situation into a
payday
but i thought the lawyer is is he
involved charged with extortion is the
lawyer for
these two deandre baker is he in trouble
too
well it's the lawyer this is where it
gets even weirder
it's the lawyer representing the
witnesses slash
victims who got charged with extortion
but then the lawyer for quentin dunbar
was under scrutiny for being involved in
this effort
to pay off witness to see there's a gray
area there between
paying off witnesses to influence
testimony and also
seeking the money because you're
extorting money
from these potential criminal defendants
and basically
everyone ends up being compromised and
the only winners in all this are the
guys who very well may have committed a
crime
but it's never going to be proven
because you have no one
that you can now put on a witness stand
that anyone's going to believe because
it's
all been tainted by the the profit
motive that pops up when people realize
hey you know that crime i just reported
maybe i can change my testimony if
somebody's going to give me some money
to do so
deandre baker ends up with the kansas
city chiefs on their practice squad
is he any good well you know he wasn't
great last year
but he was a first round pick so
somebody saw something in the guy to
bring him into the nfl
at a fairly high level and if the chiefs
believe
that that they can work him into their
system and that's the thing about the
practice squad that you've got 16 guys
because of the covet protocols
you have a spot to burn bring him in see
what he has it's low risk it's low money
and if you like him you bring him up to
the active roster and you put him on the
field if you don't like him you just
sever ties and move on to someone else i
think it's smart
for the chiefs to do it and yeah he now
has an opportunity to finish
a very difficult and challenging year
with a potential super bowl appearance
will the newest allegations against
antonio brown be enough for
the league to step in first of all
explain what happened and
did he violate his contract already well
and and you've got three different
parties that may care about what
happened on october 15. you've got the
buccaneers
who already have issued a statement
making it clear that they don't care
you've got the league and then you've
got the authorities who have
responsibility for
antonio brown's felony probation dating
back
to the incident in january with the
driver of a moving truck he's on
probation for a felony
so one false move and you get thrown in
jail so
what happened on october 15 allegedly he
broke a security camera
at a gated community he resides at in
florida he allegedly
threw a bike at a security guard shack
the
homeowners association decided not to
press charges
but police concluded there was probable
cause to find him guilty of misdemeanor
criminal mischief
so from the authorities perspective
is that enough to attack his probation
that's one question that hasn't been
resolved yet from the league's
perspective
this guy's a repeat offender is this
enough even if he's not charged and
we've seen guys get suspended
without ever being arrested like ezekiel
elliott is this enough but there's a
separate issue dan
under the terms of the personal conduct
policy if you're involved in an incident
even if you're not arrested you've got
an
obligation to tell the league and you
can be disciplined separately for that
and the league yesterday through its
in-house media conglomerate reported
that it didn't know about this
so brown didn't tell them about it when
it happened
that could be a separate ground for
disciplining him
based upon his history suspending him
you know he's still got this open
issue arising from the civil lawsuit
alleging sexual assault and rape
that the league just kicked the can they
didn't do anything they're going to wait
and see what the court does
they didn't want to take a position one
way or the other which is kind of
ludicrous to me if you're going to have
an in-house justice system at some point
you need to issue a verdict
their verdict is we'll just wait and see
what happens but if they are motivated
to go after him
they already have enough just based on
the fact if it's true
as reported by nfl media that he didn't
disclose it to the league
so look at the end of the day dan we've
seen this time and again over the past
10 years
the league is going to do what it wants
when it wants
how it wants and it has enough cover to
do basically whatever it chooses to do
in any one case
so we sit back and we wait and see
whatever inclination they may have if
they want to suspend him again
they can if they want to look the other
way they can and we just wait and see
what happens
uh we're talking to mike florio pro
football talk uh live co-host
i brought this up when alex smith got in
the game a couple of weeks ago and i
said to him do
you have your comeback player of the
year award speech ready
and then all of a sudden i had somebody
say well you're forgetting about ben
roethlisberger
and i thought okay ben coming back from
armed surgery he's
you know i guess uh implanted himself in
the mvp candidate sea race
but alex smith came back from nearly
dying nearly losing his leg
to throwing for over 300 yards in a ga
like i don't
i i don't know if it matters to either
one of these players winning comeback
player of the year award but
it feels like what alex smith did is a
whole lot different than what ben
roethlisberger has done even though ben
has played at a very high level and
they're undefeated
where do you stand well and i agree with
you
coming back from near amputation
and near death is significant
and it's unprecedented we're always
going to have somebody who comes back
from an injury and plays
well so i think the fact that this one
is so different sets it apart and part
of the problem is
nobody knows what it means to be the
comeback player of the year ryan
tannehill won it last year shereen
williams who works with us at pft so
what did he come back from
stinking does that does that make you
the comeback player of the year i'm
what what i remember when matthew
stafford won it
he never was in a position to be coming
back
it was just the first year he was any
good so
there's no definition for it and i know
peter king who's got one of the votes
said before alex smith even played in a
game
all he's got to do is take one snap yeah
and he gets my vote and i have a feeling
a lot of the 50 voters feel the same way
i'll leave you with this with a quick
response if kyler murray
wins the nfc with the cardinals dot dot
dot
mvp oh without question oh okay if he
wins if he
well now if he's the one seed and he
very well could end up taking the
cardinals to the one seat but this guy's
going to be potentially and he's on
track to be the first
player in league history to throw for 4
000 yards and rush for a thousand yards
everything he does is exciting i wish
more of his games were on a national
platform so we could all appreciate how
good he is
i've never seen anyone like him the
combination of speed agility and
awareness
it is so fun to watch him and i can't
wait to see him on thursday night and i
hope
that we get to see him more times before
the end of the season great to talk to
you mike thank you